hey there do you want to hear about four
tips to improve your speaking
skills four essential speaking tips one
pronounce words correctly pronouncing
words correctly will give you and your
listeners confidence two listen to
spoken English with podcasts Audi book
radio talk shows and television you can
easily absorb hours of English language
three read aloud reading aloud makes it
easier to remember what you're reading
which can be great for boosting
vocabulary and four practice public
speaking delivering a monologue in front
of an audience is a great way to build
up your confidence and to improve your
speaking
skills so starting today take your time
and keep practicing if you like our
content make sure to subscribe like and
comment below if you have any other
strategies how to improve your speaking
skill